ونحييكم مشاهدينا الى هذه التغطيه
المستمره للتطورات الدراماتيكيه في
السودان المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع
مستمره ومعها تتعاقد محاولات خروج
المدنيين من مناطق الاشتباكات وتتوالت
تحذيرات الامميه من ان نقص الغذائي
والمياه والوقود في البلاد يزداد حده
وبخاصه في العاصمه الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
لقد خرجنا الحمض الاربعينيه هذه السفينه
من بورسودان الى جده
طلعنا من الخرطوم الى سنجه وطريقنا كان في
مناوشات في اطلاق نار صحراويه حتى وصل
وفي اخر التفاصيل اصدر الجيش السوداني
بيانا شجب خلاله الخروقات العديده التي
اقترفها الدعم السريع للهدنه بحسب تعبيره
الجيش قال ان مجموعات الدعم السريع تواصل
تحركاتها داخل وخارج الخرطوم برغم هذه
الهدنه حيث رصد الجيش تحركات لارتال
عسكريه متجهه من غرب السودان الى الخرطوم
اضافه الى محاولات مجموعات من الدعم
السريع السيطره على مصفى الجيلي للتحكم
بالوقود الجيش اتهم الدعم السريع باستغلال
الهده لانقاذ موقفها العمليتي الذي وصفه
بالمتدهور عبر نشر قناصه في الخرطوم
وولايه اخرى
[موسيقى]
وفي المقابل اتهمت قوته الدعم السريع قوات
الجيش باستهدافي مواقعها قرب القصر
الجمهوري بالخرطوم وقلب بيان الدعم السريع
ان هذا الاستهداف يعد انتهاكا للهدنات
المعلنه مؤكدا ان القذف العشوائيه للجيش
يهدد حياه المدنيين ورعايه دول الاجنبيه
في الخرطوم كما اشارت قوه الدعم السريع في
بيان لها الى ان كسر شروط الهدنه المعلنه
يؤكد وجود اكثر من مركز قرار داخل قياده
الجيش واعادت دعم السريع التاكيد على
التزامه بشروط الهدنه لفتح ممرات انسانيه
للمدنيين والمقيمين الاجانب
وكانت العربيه رصدت الدمار الذي لحق باحد
ما شاف الخرطوم مشافي الخرطوم جراء
الاشتباكات وسقوط قذائف داخله نتابع
هذا المركز الصحي يمكن ان نشاهد الخليفه
وهي هي بقايا من هذه الرايه التي وقعت هذه
الخليفه في هذه المركز مركز الرومي الطبي
والجدير بالذكر ان هذا المركز يستانف
العمل داخله بالامس بما اعلن اغلاق المركز
بعد وصول هذه الكلمه اكثر من 10 اصابات
هذه كما ترون القضاء
الانقطع في هذا المركز الصوتي وان هنالك
تماما اثراء هذه الاشتباكات التي حدثت في
الشارع
مركز الرومان هذا
المركز
كبيره وهو مستنصر خاصه كبيره
وكان المصابون الذين اصيبوا
[موسيقى]
طبيه كبيره لمختلف التخصصات تخصصات القلب
تخصصات الباطنيه تخصصات الولاده تخصصات
الموجات
الاشعه هذه المركز يعتبر من المراكز
المهمه في مدينه ام درمان
الساعه
مستشفى البان جديد نفس الاسطاف الموجود من
اول يوم
للسماء الموجود لليوم ال11 مستشفى البان
جديد
المصابين يتوافدون الينا من منطقه كافوري
الاسطاف ما زال هو نفس الاصطاف نفس
الاستاذ 25 ابريل
ومشاهدينا بعد اتهامات الجيش لها باستهداف
البعثات الدبلوماسيه قالت قوه الدعم
السريع انها تنسق مع البعثات الدبلوماسيه
والمنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه ما اسهم في
اجلاء الرعايه الى اماكن امنه واكد بيان
الدعم السريع انه متمسكون بالهدنه مشيرا
الى ان هذا الالتزام نابع من مسؤوليتها
الاخلاقيه والتزامها للدول التي طالبت
بتجديد الهدنه لفتح ممرات انسانيه
هذا ونشرت قوه الدعم السريع صورا لمقاله
انه تامين الشاحنات المصريه لمنطقه قرى
الحره شمال الخرطوم تابع بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم نحن الان في السوق الحر لمنطقه
قريه
هذه الشاحنات طبعا شاحنات مصريه مع
اخواننا المصريين الان يعني قوات الدعم
السريع تؤمن كل هذا السوق والبترول ونحن
الان يعني حتى اخواننا المصريين معنا هنا
فنسمع منه يعني
كلمه حق يعني اتجاه قوات الدعم السريع
وتامين لهم حتى هم معانا الان يعني
واهم في تطوراتنا اخرى نشد عدد من
المواطنين في السودان عبر كاميرا العربيه
جميع الاطراف في السودان لوقف القتال
ولتامين احتياجات المواطنين وتامين
المحلات التجاريه التي تعرضت للنهب
والسلبي خلال الاشتباكات لا للصرغه نحن ما
حرامين احنا سودانيين
على حق غيرك بانه الناس الشعب السوداني
تعب لانه حاصل غلاء في الوطن السودان فيه
غلاه شديد لا فيه مويه لا في كهرباء الناس
متجهه لبخاع السودان نسبه الضيق المعيشه
في البلد وعدم توفر الامان
في الشارع لو نزلت الشرطه امنتوا
المواطنين نزلته البنزين نزلت كل الناس
حترتاح
العنصريه نتكلم عن الجنسيه السودانيه وفقط
ونتكلم عن انسان سوداني انسان سوداني
محترم لا يقبل لا يقبل عن يميد يده لحق
غيره نتكلم عن الحوادث السالبه اللي حصلت
في المحنه دي
[موسيقى]
قررت حكومه شمال كردفان وسط السودان فرضا
حظر التجوال الليلي بالولايه ابتداء من
الساعه العاشره مساء وحتى الخامسه صباحا
بالتوقيت المحلي ودعا للولايه فضل الله
توم الى تضافر الجهود والعمل من اجل تحقيق
الامن والاستقرار والسلم المجتمعي وخلال
اجتماعا انضم لجنه امن الولايه واعضاء
حكومتها وجهها المجتمعون بتقديم الدعم
والاسناد اللازم للجيش
استنفار دبلوماسي في شتى الدول الاثر
اشتباكات السودان
عمليه اجلاء الرعايا على قدم وساق
الولايات المتحده اجلت 100 شخص بثلاث
مروحيات حلقت من جيبوتي مرورا باثيوبيا
وصولا الى السودان
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه والامنيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل قال ان اكثر
من الف من رعايانا غادروا السودان فرنسا
اجلت ما يقارب
538 فردا بينهم اوروبيون وافارقه اما
ايطاليا فاغلقت سفارتها في الخرطوم
وطلبت من 200 شخص ترك الاراضي السودانيه
في حين تنتظر المانيا وصول طائره رابعه
للاجلاء مع ايصال 500 شخص الى بر الامان
واجلت طائره اسبانيه 100 شخص بينهم 30
اسبانيا وسبعون من اوروبا وامريكا
اللاتينيه وايرلندا بواقع 150 شخصا كما تم
اجلاء نحو 25 نمساويا
وتسعه رومانيين وخمسه مجريين و 21 بلغاريا
بمساعده دول اخرى
ومشاهدينا معنا من منطقه المعموره جنوب
الخرطوم مراسله العربيه ريان ظاهر ريان
اهلا بك معنا
فقدناه الاتصال بريان طيب نعود لها بعد
قليل بعد ان نستكمل بعض الاخبار الصله
ونحللها قبل عرض تفاصيلها مع ضيفنا من
باريس الكاتب السودانيه المتخصص بشؤون
الافريقيه محمد توشين سيد محمد اهلا بك
معنا مبدئيا اسمح لي ان نبدا بموضوع
الاجلاء اجلاء الرعايه هذا الموضوع اهتمت
به كل الجهات بداخل السوداني وكل الاطراف
تحدثت عن تقديمها لمساعدات لمحاوله تامين
اما هذه القوافل برا او كذلك لمحاوله
الابتعاد عن محيط المطارات ولكن لما تجتمع
الدول على اجلاء رعاياها هل هذا ينظر
باشتداد المعارك بعد الانتهاء من هذه
المرحله تعتقد
هذا مؤشر سلبي يعكس حاله التوجس وفقدان
الامل لدى القوى التي ظلت فاعله في الشان
السوداني لازم الدول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بحيث هذه الدول كان
لديها رؤيه
تنجح المبادرات المرتبطه بوقف اطلاق النار
حتى الدخول في مفاوضات مباشره لكن من خلال
متابعتها للاوضاح السودان وكذلك تحليل على
بعض البيانات المخابراتيه تاكدت بان هذه
الاوضاع ربما ذاهبه الى الفصل الاول
المتواصل من قبل الطرفين النزاع بان
التصريحات توشي بذلك فضلا عن ذلك هنالك
تحشيش من قبل الطرفين ويستغلال
وهنالك بعض المؤشرات تتحدث عن الدور
الاقليمي فاعل في هذه المساله في ظل
التجاذبات وفي ظل رغبه بعض الدوليه ان
يكون لديها غدا في افريقيا فكل هذه
المعطيات تؤكد بان ربما الاوضاع
مزيد من التوضيح في مقبل الايام مهما
تحدثنا عن هنالك رغبه
من اطراف الصراع الى حد ما بالاضافه الى
المجتمع الدولي لكن التناقضات والتجاذبيه
دور كبير جدا جدا في استمرار باننا سنعود
لهذا الموضوع
وسنعود لهذه التاثيرات وتداعيات الازمه في
السودان على مناطق الجوار ودول الجوار
تفضل بالبقاء معي سيد محمد يعود لك بعد
قليل بعد استطلاع الاوضاع في جنوب الخرطوم
في منطقه المعموره بالتحديد مع مراسلات
العربيه ريان ظاهر ريان صرتي جاهزه معنا
كيف هي صوره من عندك ما هي الاعداد خاصه
وكيف تبدو الصعوبات لانك تكلمت في نشرات
سابقه عن ثمن التذاكر استغله البعض
عن هناك صعوبات ومخاوف امنيه كذلك تتعلق
بطريقه التنقل في دعينا في اطار كل هذه
التفاصيل
اولا انا في منطقه لفه جبى هنا عدد من
البساط والمركبات السفريه عدد من
المسافرين الذين يستعدون لمغادره الخرطوم
بعضهم يذهب الى الولايه الشماليه ومن ثم
الحدود ومن ثم الدخول الى مصر والبعض
الاخر يتجه الى يعني عدد من ولايات
السودان المختلفه حيث يقطنون هنالك
اهاليهم اهاليهم يوجدون هناك قصص صراحه
صعبه وماساويه العيش هنا في الخرطوم لا
يطاق بالنسبه للكثيرين شحا الوقود والمواد
الغذائيه والتموينيه وايضا يعني قله المال
او النقود يعني لا يمتلكون نقدا وبالتالي
اسعار التذاكر ايضا صعبه ومرتفعه للغايه
يبررون اصحاب المركبات بان الوقود في
الخرطوم يجعله
يزيدون تكلفه التذاكر والبعض يقول بانها
باهظه قد تتراوح الى 300 الف جنيه سوداني
للمسافر الواحد وهو مبلغ كبير للغايه
استطلعت بعض
المسافرين
وقاموا بسرد كثير من التفاصيل انا لا
اسمعك جيدا
اي سؤال لا لا تفضل لاكملي
تذاكر الباهظه وايضا المواد الغذائيه
والمحال المغلقه لو تتوجه الكاميرا جميع
هذه المحال مغلقه تماما والصيدليات وايضا
حتى الافران والمخابز
ان فتحت ابوابها
لتوقيت معين لدقائق معينه او ساعات معينه
ومن ثم تغلق ابوابها وايضا نشاط صفوف من
من الناس يعني يقتضون امام هذه المحاليل
شراء الخبز وبعض المواد الغذائيه
صحيح ولكن ساعود معك لهذه التفاصيل لشرح
الغذاء وانقطاع المياه ولكن كنت تحدثين عن
عمليات النزوح لو نفسر كيف تتم او يتم
تنظيم هذه العمليه يعني عدد الحافلات من
يؤمن عمليه
الانتقال كيف تتم هذه التفاصيل بالتحديد
كنا نودنا الحديث اكثر مع اصحاب هؤلاء
المركبات التي يعني تذهب بعيدا الى الحدود
لكن هم مستعجلون
نؤخرهم او نعطلهم قليلا لكن ما استطعت ان
افهمه منهم انها عدد قليل من المركبات نحن
نقف قرب اربع بساط سياحيه او سفريه تستعد
للسفر بالداخل مكتظه تماما يعني بالركاب
نود الحديث مع
لا اعلم ان كانت هنالك بعض السيدات التي
يريدنا الحديث
الكاميرا ستوجه اليهم تفضلي
نعم
ونحن مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور
لنزوح بعض السودانيين من جنوب الخرطوم
بالتحديد
واتجاههم الى الولايه الشماليه الى لفه هم
في
نووي
[موسيقى]
نوبري كان هيلفاز
هو طبعا يشتكي من قله البصات وهو يقول
الان انه وجد باص ويشتغل ايضا من قله
الوقود
يتحدثون عن ان السفاره السفاره
الهنديه بالسودان قامت بمساعدته وبالتالي
المساعده في اجلائهم لا اعلم مرحبا
معنا
[موسيقى]
الان عدد من
الجاليات الهنديه الجاليه الهنديه عدد من
الركاك مرحبا
وهم ايضا هذا احد يعني ابناء الجاليه
الهنديه يوعد بانه يريد ان يرجع من جديد
الى السودان في حال يعني
احد ابناء الجاليه الهنديه بانه يوجد في
السودان لثلاث سنوات وحاليا يلتحق بعائلته
بالهند هنا ابناء الجاليه الهنديه يتجهون
خارج السودان بعد فتره قضوها داخل العاصمه
الخرطوم وتبدو عليهم كثير من علامات
الاستفهام يعني صراحه بوجوههم سنتواصل
معكم وسنستطلع مزيد من الناس اللي موجودين
هنا مرحبا مرحبا
مرحبا اخواننا واصدقائنا عن جيراننا الله
اخواننا ومشيرين بها جدا جدا انا الهادي
عيسى من اولاد المزيريه وتسليم من اخواننا
الاجانب والله شديد علموا معنا
اليوم الاجانب راحلين من السودان نسرين من
الاجانب رايحين من السودان والله ان شاء
الله ربنا
تعاملهم معانا كويس
الوضع والله سيء
زي بقيه كل الناس السافرت
استطاعه ما في لانه ما في سيوله ما في مال
ما في قروش ما في نقود قروش والله
وشكرا جزيلا جزاكم الله خيرا
اذا عدد من الجميع الجميع يشكي من شحا
النقود والسيول ونحن نتابع معك دائما هذه
الصور
ولا حتكون موجود هنا بالخرطوم
ماشي ان شاء الله انت واسرتك انا اسرتي
المنطقه اللي انت فيها الظروف اللي انت
فيها والله الظروف لا تخفى على احد طبعا
الظروف كلها سيئه جدا
والناس دخلت في حته ضيقه جدا جدا بسبب
الصراع الموجود ده
صراع انا ما اعرف كل كل قاصر طبعا كل
الجهات قاصره
انا كنت هنا طبعا
فطلعنا منها طلعنا
في العربيه هنا
اطلع يعني
بس الحاصل
والله كلها كانت في راسها كلها كانت في
راسنا اصوات النيران والرصاص والدانات
والقذايف يعني احنا عشنا ايام هنا في
الكويت كانت رعب وكانت خوف وكانت الناس ما
لاقيها يعني طريقه تطلع عشان تعمل حاجه
وحتى بعد ما تطلع ما بتلقى حاجه محلات
مقفله الوضع معروف طبعا
ربنا يلطف بالناس
يعني اتمنى انها تقيف وبنطالب انه الطرفين
ارجعوا لصوت العقل عشان المواطن السوداني
عشان البلد عشان الوطن لانه كذا ما في شخص
مستفيد ما في جهه مستفيده الطرفين خسرانه
خاسرين والبلد خسرانه والمواطن خسران
يعني هي امنيات الجميع ان ينصلح الحال
اعود والقاكم من جديد ونستطلع ايضا عدد من
المسافرين نحن بهذه المنطقه باننا سنكون
معك في لقاءات اخرى لمتابعه هذه العمليه
ومتابعه تفاصيلها كذلك اود شكرا
زميلتنا ريان ظاهر مراسله العربيه من
منطقه جنوب الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
نتابع ونعود من جديد لضيفنا من باريس
الكاتب السوداني المتخصص بشؤون الافريقيه
محمد توشين سيد محمد كنت تحدثني حضرتك
تتحدث عن تاثير وتداعيات ما يحدث في داخل
السوداني على دول الجوار ما المخاوف
المتعلقه بامكانيه ان تنسحب الازمه
السودانيه على الحدود اولا ومن ثم كيف
يمكن ان تكون تداعياتها على المنطقه عموما
حلفائها على ارض الواقع فبالتالي هنالك
فرضيه وامكانيه لتسليح مجموعات اخرى
الجزئيه الاخيره والمهمه انا في تقدير
ايضا تداعيات على الامن والاستقرار
المنطقه وان السوداني عده من الاحزمه او
الدول التي تعاني منها تعاني اضطرابات
مرتبطه بالارهاب وكذلك الجرائم والعابره
بشؤون الافريقيه ما هي الدول القدره على
ان تكون اكثر تضرر نتيجه للازمه في
السودان
الدول الاكثر تضررا الان
كبير جدا مصر ستضرر باعتبار ان مصر قبل
هذه الاحداث تطلب اكثر من خمسه مليون
سوداني اذا استمرت هذه الاحداث يمكن ان
يلتحق بهم خمسه مليون او اكثر كذلك جاءت
هي تحتضن واعاده كبيره جدا من اللاجئين
يبان الحرب التي اندلعت من عام 2003 والان
عور اكثر من 50,000 الى الجاري
هؤلاء سيتاثرون بلا شكله بلا شكوى سيضعون
كذلك الجهات التي تقدم العون الانساني الى
هؤلاء في تحدي حقيقي في ظل عدم موضوع تصور
او وضع تصور وكذلك رؤيه يمكن من خلالها
تقديم الخدمات لهؤلاء فبالتالي انا في
تقدير استدعيات الانسانيه ستكون وخيمه جدا
وستكسر على تلك البلد باعتبار الكثير من
هذه البلدان هي بلدان ايضا تعاني من من
اقتصاديات هشه تعاني من عدم الاستقرار
كذلك فرص الاستقرار فيها شبه معدومه كل
هذه العوامل تجعل من الصعب جدا ان حتى
يستقرها هؤلاء عندما ينتغلون هناك
فبالتالي
تعقيدات مهمه جدا من الاوروبيين له لا دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي ينظرون الى الازمه في
السودان بشيء من الخيطه وبشيء من الخشيه
باع
تبارها نف
ر الملايين من المهاجرين الذين ياتون من
القرن الافريقي ويودون الذهاب الى اوروبا
وهذا ايضا مهدد
بما انك تتحدث عن مخاوف متعلقه بان
المنطقه ككل وليس فقط بداخل السوداني
منتظر من
الاتحاد الافريقي بمعنى ان الاتحاد
الافريقي كانت له تصريحات وكانت له منشدات
ولكن في النهايه ما نتابعه من وسطات
ومبادرات حقيقيه اتت اما امميه او من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الاتحاد
الافريقي ما دور في هذه الاثناء في هذه
المرحله الصعبه
انا اتوقع انه الولاده المتحده الامريكيه
ستتدخل بكل ثقله وكل نفوذه في المنطقه
معلومه الولايات المتحده لديها نفوس كبير
جدا في منطقه القرن الافريقي والبحيرات
العظمى والان بدات هذه الرؤيه تتبلور بشكل
جلي من خلال التواصل المستمر بين الوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي وزير الخارجيه الكيني
باعتبار ان منذ بدايه الاحداث انعقد
اجتماع للايجاد وكذلك السلم والامن
الافريقي وكلفوا الاتحاد الافريقي عمقا
للمهمه هذه مهمه تحكي في السودان بشكل
مباشر للايجاد فبالتالي الان من خلال
ويليام بروتو رئيس وكينيا وكذلك هذا
الفقير رئيس الجنوب السودان وعمر رئيس
جيبوتي سيتحركون لكن في تقدير الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ستعتمد بشكل مباشر على
كينيا الاعتبارات عديده ان النظام في
كينيا هو نظام ديمقراطي لديهم ايضا على
حجه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ربما لا تعاون
كثيرا
الامم المتحده بيعتبر ان هنالك نفوس لبعض
القوه التي تتقاطع مصالحها مع الولايات
المتحده وضحت الفكره سننتظر لنرى كيف
ستدار الامور في الساعات والايام القادمه
شكرا جزيلا لك من باريس الكاتب السوداني
المتخصص بشؤون الافريقيه
نتابع دائما مناقشه ومحاوله فهم هذه
التطورات بالتحليل مع ضيفنا من القاهره
السفير صلاح حليمه مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الاسبق ورئيس مكتب الجامعه العربيه في
السودان سابقا اهلا بك معنا سفير صلاح
اسمح لي ان ابدا معك
بما قاله الطرفان بخصوص تامين
المجموعات الدبلوماسيه وتامين خروجها خاصه
فيما الواقع يتحدث عن استهدفات حضرتك
دبلوماسي كيف تتابع هذه التطورات
الامر فيما يتعلق بالنقطه الاولى هذا ربما
يكون مؤشر على ان الطرفان يعني علاقتهما
بمصر تسير في اتجاه ممكن ان يكون هناك
قبول لاي دور او تحرك من جانب مصر فيما
يتعلق بتطورات الازمه في السودان
ايضا ما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار وان تكون
هناك هدنه للاسف ربما هذه الهدنه لقيت ولو
قدر من من التعامل معها بشكل افضل من
سابقه من سابقيها لكن ما زال هناك خرقات
خروقات فيما يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار وايضا
فيما يتعلق حتى بعمليه النزوح وتوفير
الممرات امنه
اتمام عمليه الاغاثه بشكل المنشود من هنا
انا اعتقد ان عمليه وقفه
تحتاج الى ضروره وجود اليه للمراقبه
والتدقيق بين بين الطرفي الصراع على النحو
الذي لا يمكن ان تكون الاوضاع في الخرطوم
بصفه خاصه ولكن تميل الى ترجيح امكانيه
استمرار الهدنه صحيح لما نتحدث عن ضروره
المراقبه والتدقيق فيما يخص هذه الهدنه
والالتزام بها من الاطراف الموكل لها
التدقيق والمتابعه وفرض التزام مختلف
الاطراف بهذه الهدنه
نحن نتذكر ان الامم المتحده كانت
يعني
اوفدت بعث لدعم العمليه عمليه تحول
الديمقراطي في السودان اثناء تولي الرئيس
الوزراء حمدوك السلطه وبناء على طلبه وهذه
البعثه ايضا تم افاد مبعوث الامم المتحده
فولكر في استنادا الى هذه البعثه وانطلاقا
منها وبالتالي الموضوع فيما يتعلق بوقف
اطلاق النار يجب ان يكون في اطار اممي
وتشارك فيه كافه الاليات التي تتولى عمليه
اداره الازمه بذلك الاليه الثلاثيه
والاليه الرباعيه فضلا عن الدول الدول
الجوار
المعنيه بالشان السوداني فضلا ايضا عن
الدول المهتمه من القوى الكبرى من حيث
يكون هذا هذا هذا القرار قرار اممي من
المجتمع الدوله بمكوناتها وانا اشير في
هذا الصدد كنموذج يمكن الاعتزاء به
الاجتماع الذي تم من جانب الامم المتحده
مع المنظمات الاقليميه والدوليه المعنيه
بشان السوداني وايضا مع الدول المعنيه
بشان السوداني بسيوبيا ومصر وجنوب السودان
واصدروا بيان يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار
والاغاثه والى اخره هذا النموذج او هذا
الاجتماع ممكن ان يتكرر لبحث وضع هذه
الاليه وايضا ضروره البدء في نفس الوقت مع
العمليه السياسيه على النحو الذي يمكن معه
السير نحو تحقيق اماني شعبه السوداني
وخيارات بتوسيع الاليه
الاتفاق الاتفاق الايطالي وانضمام الكتله
الديمقراطيه وايضا الكتل المعارضه او
المتحفظه بحيث يكون الاتفاق الايطالي
اتفاقا شاملا يعالج العيوب والمسالك الذي
كانت في
مراحل المتقدمه استاذ صلاح صحيح ساعود لك
بخصوص هذه النقاط ولكن اسمح لي ان اذكر
ببعض الاخبار ذات الصله فتفضل بالبقاء
معنا هناك تطورات عديده فيما يخص هذا
الملف خاصه حيث اعرب رئيس مجموعه البنك
الدولي ديفيد مالباس عن شكره للعاهل
السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز على
اسهام المملكه ومساعدتها في اجلاء منسوبي
البنك من السودان الى المملكه
وسمى في خطاب بعثه للملك سلمان دوره سفاره
المملكه لدى السودان على الرعايه
والاهتمام لمنسوبي البنك ولعائلتهم الذي
كان له الاثر الكبير في ظل هذه الازمه
من جهتي قال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
جيمس كليفرلي انه تحدث مع طرفها يا صراع
في السودان مؤكدا انه سيواصل الضغط على
القوتين من اجل الالتزام بوقف دائما
لاطلاق النار
لقد تحدثت بشكل مباشر ومن خلال وسطاء مع
الاطراف المتصارعه وقمت بدعوتهم الى
السماح باجلاء المواطنين البريطانيين
ومزدوجه الجنسيه والاطفال وسنواصل الضغط
من اجل الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار بالطبع
من المستحيل ان نتنبا بالوقت الذي سيستمر
فيه الهدوء ونحن ندعم مواطنينا الى ترك
الاولويه للاشد حاجه الى الاجلاء
قال ايضا ان الوضع لا يزال خطيرا ومتقلبا
ولا يمكن التنبؤ به في السودان بحسب
تعبيره كيف
بالعصيد
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه قمنا بتخطيط
مكثف عبر الادارات الحكوميه ومع شركائنا
الدوليين للاستفاده من اي تحسن في الوضع
على الارض للبدء في اجلاء الرعايه
البريطانيين في السودان يسعدني جدا اعلان
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل قاده الفصائل على
الارض وبالتالي بدانا عمليات الاجلاء من
المهم ان نتذكر انه تم خلق كل اعلانات وقف
اطلاق النار سابقا وبالتالي فان الوضع لا
يزال خطيرا ومتقلبا ولا يمكن التنبؤ به
واما فرنسا فقد اعلنت انتهاء عمليات
الاجلاء نحو جيبوتي وقالت هيئه واركان
الجيوش الفرنسيه انها ابقى على فرقاطه في
بورسودان لمساعده الامم المتحده في عمليه
الاجلاء نحو جده كما اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
والدفاع الفرنسيه في بيان مشترك اننا عدد
الجنسيات التي استفادت من عمليات الاجلاء
الفرنسيه ارتفع الى 41 جنسيا واشار البيان
الى ان عمليات الاجلاء حصلت من نقاط
التجمع في الخرطوم نحو قاعده وادي سيدنا
ومن القاعده جوا الى جيبوتي
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه انها لا
تخطط للمزيد مرحله الاجلاء الالمانيه من
السودان مشيره الى ان اخر رحله اجلاء من
السودان الى الاردن ستنطلق مساء اليوم
واوضحت الخارجيه الالمانيه ان دولا شركه
ستتولى اجلاء المواطنين الالمان المتبقين
في السودان خلال الايام المقبله
الشمالي بمدينه بورسودان بولايه البحر
الاحمر بشرق السودان هنا تستمر عمليه
الاجلاء لمئات من رعايه الدول العربيه
والاوروبيه والاسيويه التي بدات من
الخرطوم العاصمه برا الى شرق السودان
ومنها عبر البحر الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبعدها يغادرون الى دولهم عمليه
الاجلاء تمضي تحت اشراف كامل من قبل الجيش
السوداني عبر مسارين بحري وجوي وكانت
العديد من الدول العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه قد شرعت في التنسيق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في الترتيب لاجلاء
رعاياها خلال الساعات الماضيه
في هذه المرحله من مراحل عمليه الاجلاء
التي بدات هنا في شرق السودان يتم الوصول
الى هذه المرحله وهي مرحله الاستوثاق من
الاوراق الثبوتيه ومن الجوازات هنا تقوم
الشرطه السودانيه ممثله في اداره الجوازات
والهجره بالتعرف على كافه الاوراق
الثبوتيه وجوازات السفر تمهيدا
لنقلهم عبر الباخره الى المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ومنها الى بقيه دولهم هنا
292 من رعايه دوله الهند بالسودان اكملوا
اجراءات مغادرتهم واجلائهم من مدينه
بورسودان الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ومنها الى دولتهم فيما ينتظر اخرون
استكمال اجراءاتهم لمغادره البلاد خلال
الساعات المقبله نزار البغداوي لقناتي
العربيه والحدث الميناء الشمالي مدينه
بورسودان شرقيه السودان
مشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نتابع هذه الصور
كانت نشرتها قوات دعم سريع وتحدثت فيها عن
استهدافها وكذلك سيطرتها على مصفاه جري
نتابع هذه الصور نذكر فقط بان هذه الصور
تاتي بعد بيان اصدرته قوات الدعم السريع
قالت فيه بانها فعلا اما نات شاحنات
المصريه بمنطقه جري الحره وسيطرت علم
الصفات نتابع هذه الصور ونعود النبي
اولا نترحم على شهداء قوات الدعم السريع
نترحم على شهداء قوات الدعم السريع ونقول
للاعلام والمضلل
وشاهدناه وسمعناه
انه الفلول مسيطرين
على المصفى وما حوله او محاوله لسيطرتهم
ولكن نقول لهم هيهات والله نحنا من الحاج
يوسف
[موسيقى]
وكافوري وشمباز
وشمالا تحدي التصنيع الحربي وجبن الطير
وحجر عسل
وجنوب منه اربعين كيلو وشرق منه اربعين
كيلو وغريب منها لحد البحر
كلامنا معكم لا يسمح
ودين
وشمالا على السودان نسبه 200%
اذا كما كنا نتابع كانت هذه كلمه من احد
عناصر قوات الدعم السريع الذي اكد من خلال
هذا الفيديو سيطره قوات الدعم السريع على
مصفاه جاري اعود من جديد الى ضيفي من
القاهره سفير صلاح اليمامه مساعد وزير
الخارجيه المصري الاسبق ورئيس مكتب
الجامعه العربيه في السودان سابقا سفير
صلاح من جديد اهلا بك معنا كنت تحدثنا قبل
التذكير ببعض الاخبار تحدثنا عن وجوب
العوده والالتزام بالاتفاق الاطاري وان
يجلس الاطراف كافه على طويل التفاوض ولكن
قبل كل هذا كيف يمكن ان تخدم المسالك
الدبلوماسيه كل ما هو تطورات عسكريه بمعنى
كيف تخدم الدبلوماسيه بحسب خبره حضرتك ما
يحدث من تطورات اليوم
هو طبعا لا شك ان هذا الامر مرتبط
بتحرك الاليات التي تتولى عمليه اداره
الازمه سواء كانت الاليه الثلاثيه او
الاليه الرباعيه وفي هذا الصدد علينا ان
نشير الى ان هذه الاليه وتلك يجب ان يتم
دعمها
بعناصر اخرى مثل الجامعه العربيه كاليه
تدخل مع الاليه الثلاثيه باعتبار انها
اليه منظمه
والاليه الرباعيه
اعتقد انها يمكن ان يطاف اليها الدول
المعنيه بالشان السوداني بشكل مباشر ولا
دور بحوري فيه وهي مثل مصر على سبيل
المثال وايضا جنوب السودان وربما ايضا
تشاد وهذا كله في اطار تعاون اممي مع
الامم المتحده وفي اطار مجلس الامن الذي
اوفد باس الدعم لعمليه تحول الديمق ثم
اوفى الناس فولكر للقيام بعمليه تسيير
الحوار السوداني السوداني وهذا يتم بالقطع
في اطار الفصل السادس والفصل السابع من
ميثاق المتحده الذي يتعلق بموضوعات الامن
والسلم الاقليمي والدولي من هنا في هذا
التصور لابد ايضا ان يكون الاتفاق
الايطالي وقد كان به بعض المثالب والعيوب
التي فجرت هذا الوضع الذي تعيشه السودان
الان في ان الضم ان يتم توسيع الاتفاق
الاطاري لمشاركه كتله ديمقراطيه
والعناصر والقوه الشخصيه المتحفظه
والمعترضه استاذ صلاح هذا الوضع الذي
وصفته بالمتفجر وهو فعلا متفجر
ووصلنا الى الصراع مسلح الى ازمه والبعض
يتخوف حتى من حرب اهليه ولو ان الموضوع
لاز ال مقتصر على الخرطوم ولكن حضرتك تعلم
استاذ صلاح بان هذه التطورات سبقتها
تصريحات كانت قادره على التنبؤ بانه شيئا
ما قادر ان ينفلت ان يحدث
الم يكن هناك
مقدره على تدخل احدى الدول المعنيه
بالتطورات في داخل السوداني يعني سؤال
المطروح لماذا لم يتم او لم تتم وساطه منذ
بدايه الحديث عن الخلافات بين الجنرلين
خاصه
طبعا هذا سؤال جوهري الحقيقه لان كان يجب
ان يتم
بدبلوماسيه وقائيه
يعني احتواء مثل هذه المواقف التي ادت الى
هذا التسارع وانا اعتقد ان السبب في هذا
الامر بكل صراحه ان القائمين على اداره
الازمه سواء كانت الاليه الثلاثيه او
الاليه الرباعيه بداخلها
وهذا معروف بعض القوى التي لها توجهات
ربما دفعت في الاتجاه الخاص بما اشرت اليه
ان سالب وعيوب في الاتفاق الاطاري وهذا
الامر كان يجب معالجته قبل ان تستفحل
الامور بان يكون هناك على سبيل المثال وضع
خاص لقوه الحريه والتغيير المجلس المركزي
فيما يتعلق بهياكل السلطه الانتقاليه ايضا
كان هناك المثلث الخاص بان يكون هناك
قوتين عسك الجيش والدعم السريع في دوله
يجب ان يكون هناك فقط جيش واحد ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالمناصب التي اعطيت للدعم السريع
ومده دمج عشر سنوات وهذا امر يعني ان هناك
علامات استفهام فيما يتعلق
بالنوايه وخاصه كذلك ببعض المواقف والاكيد
باننا سنعود لكل هذه التساؤلات ولكن في
نشرات قادمه
الشكر من القاهره السفير صلاح لما مساعد
وزير الخارجيه المصري الاسبق ورئيس مكتب
الجامعه العربيه في السودان سابقا شكرا
جزيلا
ناكل ونشربه
كثير وما نقدر نرجع قدامهم هذه حاجات
كلهم
كتالونه خلاص
النزوح ومشاهدينا ذات الحله امام الكثير
من السودانيين هربا من الاغتسال الدائر
الامر الذي دفع مفوضيه الامم المتحده
لشؤون اللاجئين للتعبير عن قلقها من فرار
اكثر من 200 الف شخص الى تشاد وجنوب
السودان وقالت ممثله المفوضيه في تشاد
قالت انه وصل الى البلاد 20 الف لاجئين
حتى الان ومن المتوقع ان يتبعهم مئه الف
اخرون مشيره الى دخول 170 الف شخصا الى
جنوب السودان منذ بدء المواجهات
وضرب شديد حاصل هناك
في ضرب في الطريق وفي اتوبيسات اتضربت
وكده
يمكن اصعب لحظه التفكير في الخروج ووسط
اصوات انفجارات عنيفه وسط اصوات رصاص قرر
بانه يبعد باولاده عن اماكن النزاع بين
القوات المسلحه وبين قوات الدعم السريع
ومش كان بيقولوا في هدنه لكن حتى الهدنه
كان في حرق واضح لها يعني الواحد يتمنى
انه الحرب ينتهي وانه يرجع الامن والامان
للسودان
حول الاوضاع الصحيه المترديه جراء
المواجهات المستمره في السودان اعرب اتحاد
جمعيه الهلال والصليب الاحمر بالسودان عن
قلقه بعد 11 يوما من القتال في السودان
واكد ان المنظمه تعمل مع شركائها لاعاده
مستشفيات الخرطوم للعمل
نحن قلقون جدا بعد 11 يوما من القتال في
السودان وحتى الساعه لا يوجد اي تطور لوقف
مواد القتال ما يزيد من التحديات
الانسانيه المشكله الاساسيه التي نواجهها
هي العجز في وجود المواد الغذائيه والطبيه
وغيرها كما ارتفعت الاسعار بشكل كبير ايضا
ننسق مع الهلال الاحمر المصري والجمعيات
الاخرى لدعم جميع المحتاجين في البلاد وفي
الخرطوم العائلات عالقه في منازلها
بانتظار الاجلاء نعمل ايضا مع الهلال
الاحمر السوداني والدولي لضمان استمرار
العمل في اكثر من 60 مستشفى وت زويدها
بالمواد الطبيه
اما باتريك يوسف فالمدير الاقليمي
لافريقيا لدى اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر فقد طلب الجيش ودعم السريع باحترام
الهدنه وبوقف اطلاق النار والسماحي للفرق
الامميه والانسانيه بالعمل وبتقديم
المساعدات للمدنيين العالقين
خلال اتصالاتنا علمنا ان هناك عائلات في
الخرطوم لم تغادر منازلها منذ اكثر من
ثمانيه ايام والحركه بشكل عام في العاصمه
محدوده جدا يجب ان يكون هناك احترام لهدنه
وقف اطلاق النار من قبل الجيش والدعم
السريع ايضا ساعدنا بنجاح عمليات الاجلاء
للاجانب وعليه ندعو المجتمع الدولي الى
الاستمرار ببذل الجهود وحث السودان على
احلال السلام والسماح للفرق الانسانيه
بالعمل خاصه الهلال الاحمر السوداني
والمتطوعين الذين يتعرضون لخطر كبير هناك
نداءات لحمايه المدنيين وفرقنا التي ظلت
عالقه في مكانها تفاديا للقصف تحدثنا مع
المسؤولين في جنيف والسودان للمساعده في
اعاده العمل في المستشفيات وتوفير المياه
والكهرباء
[موسيقى]
اللجنه الدوليه لصليب الاحمر لم تقم
باجلاء
طواقمها طواقمها كلها ليست حاليا موجوده
في السودان
ما قمنا ما قمنا به هو انه بالنسبه لبعض
الفرق تم تحويل مكانها ونقلها من مدن تشتد
فيها وتيره
الاقتتال الى مدن اخرى مجاوره لكننا لم
نقم باجلاء اي
اي فريق ولا ننوي ان القيام بذلك هدفنا هو
تقديم المساعده الانسانيه في اقرب وقت
هذا وحذرت منظمه الصحه العالميه من خطر
بيولوجي كبير في السودان وقلم ممثل منظمه
لدى السودان نعمه سعيد عابد قال ان الفرق
الطبيه للمنظمه تحتفظ بمواد داخل مختبر
سيطرت عليه عناصر مسلحه واتخذت منه موقعا
عسكريا بحسب قوله من بينها مواد مختبريه
للملاريا والكوليرا او بيئه اخرى
الاحصاءات المتوفره تتحدث عن مقتل 459
شخصا واصابه اربعه الاف وخمسه وسبعين لكن
الضحايا اكثر الخطوره ايضا تكمن
بالمواجهات في شوارع العاصمه واعاقه وصول
الضحايا للمستشفيات وايضا تعطيل عمل تلك
المستشفيات كذلك احد طرفي النزاع سيطر على
مختبر طبي تابع لنا بقوه السلاح وطرد
العاملين فيه واتخذوا منه موقعا عسكريا
بينما نحذر من وجود خطر بيولوجي كبير بسبب
المواد
التي نحتفظ بها داخل المختبر بينها عينات
مخباريه للمناريه والكوليرا واوبئه اخرى
نتابع الوضع الانساني مع ضيفنا من الخرطوم
انا وسما ابو بكر المسئول والاعلاميين
للهلال الاحمر السوداني سيد اسامه اهلا بك
معنا سيد اسامه مع هذا الهدوء الحظر التي
تعيشه بعض المناطق مع تراجع خاصه وتيره
الاشتباكات هل يمكن القول بان الهلال
الاحمر السوداني عاد للعمل بطريقه عاديه
وشبه عاديه
لا لا لم نعود بطريقه عاديه لانه لا تزال
هنالك مخاطر جسيمه
ولسع في اشتباكات في مناطق متفرقه عديده
لذلك يواصل الهلال الاحمر السوداني نفعيه
وعمله في المجالات التي بدا يعمل فيها منذ
اندلاع الازمه في يوم سبت الماضي وهي اللي
هي دعم المستشفيات
بالكوادر المؤهله من المطوعين في مجال
الاسعافات الاوليه ورعايه الصحيه الاوليه
لا نزال نشتغل بنعمل بكفاءه عاليه في 18
المستشفى منتشره في جميع انحاء العاصمه
القوميه اضافه الى
العمل النوعي الذي يقوم به الهلال الاحمر
في بعض الولايات الاخرى
فضلا عن ولايه او مدينه ملوي حيث بدات
الازمه اصلا اساسا عندنا 118 متطوع
يعني يساعدوا المستشفيات والكادر الصحي في
العلاج للمصابين الان عندنا
افهم من حضرتك بانكم تعملون بطريقه محدده
خاصه على مستوى الخرطوم ومروي صحيح
اخرى اضافه الى ملوي ولايه الخرطوم تحدثت
عن ثمانيه عشر مستشفى في العاصمه الخرطوم
تحاولون ان توفروا طواقم طبيه او على
الاقل مستوى قم طبيه ولكن
عناصر مؤهله للمساعده داخل المستشفيات
نتحدث عن مستشفيات او عن ثمانيه عشر
مستشفى فقط بقيت قادره على خدمه المواطنه
السوداني
حتى هذه الثمانيه عشره مستشفى ماي احنا
اخذنا احصائيه كامله عن عدد المستشفيات في
العاصمه القوميه نجدها تفوق الميت مستشفى
سواء كانت قطاع عام او قطاع خاص لكن هذه
المستشفيات لم تعد قادره ان تعمل بشكل
طبيعي نسبه لنقص نحن كان نتناول يعني يعني
انه المستشفيات دي بتعاني بالضبط في كل
المستلزمات والصحيه كل الادوات اللازمه
للاسعاف الجرحى والمصابين فضلا عن النقص
في الكادر الطبي اساسا وهو النص في الطاقه
الكهربائيه والمياه والنقص في الوقود
اللازم للمولدات لتشغيل الطاقه الكهربائيه
اضافه لكل اللوازم المطلوبه
بسبب القدرات المستشفى لا تفصف لا تستطيع
العدد
كذلك الى جانب المستشفيات ذكرت منذ قليل
بان هناك مخاوف من التنقل لان الاشتباكات
لا زالت مستمره وان كانت متفارقه ولكن هل
تمكنتم على خلاف الايام الاولى من التنقل
مثلا الى مناطق تعذره وصولكم لها في
الايام الاولى حيث كانت الاشتباكات حاده
اي احيانا دلوقتي في بعض المناطق مثلا بين
المستشفيات في المحليات السبعه يمكن
التنقل فيها لكن بشكل عام بشكل عام ما
يقوم به الهلال الاحمر الان في دعم
الكوادر
الطبيه في المستشفيات بالكادر المؤهل في
الاسعافات الاوليه لا يع
ونتوقف سنعود لهذه التغطيه ولكن نتوقف
الان مع موجز لاهم الانباء ومتفارقات من
العالم حيث حذر سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي
نيكولاي باتروشيف مما اسماها بمحاولات
الولايات المتحده التحضير لحرب بيولوجيه
ضد روسيا ودول اخرى وشدد بتروشيف خلال
الجلسه العامه السنويه للمجلس العلمي في
اطار مجلس الامن ان الابحاث البيولوجيه
الخاصه التي تستخدمها الولايات المتحده في
تطوير برامجها العسكريه تتطلب اهتماما
كبيرا من المجلس وفق قوله
اجرى وزير الدفاع الروسي سرقه محادثات
رباعيه في موسكو مع نظرائه في ايران
وسوريا وتركيا وقالت وزاره الدفاع التركيه
ان الوزراء ناقشوا خلال هذا الاجتماع
تعزيز الامن في سوريا وتطبيع العلاقه
بينها وبين تركيا
اعلن الرئيس جو بايدن ترشحه للانتخابات
الرئاسيه عام 2024 ليصبح بعمر 80 عاما
كاكبر مرشح يخوض حمله جديده الى البيت
الابيض وكتب على تويتر انه متمسك بالدفاع
عن الديمقراطيه مشيرا الى ان الحريات
الشخصيه في امريكا تتعرض لهجوم من
الجمهورين المتطرفين على حد تعبيره
من جانبه يواجه الرئيس الامريكي والسابق
دونالد ترامب محاكمه مدنيه في منهات بتهمه
اغتصاب الكاتب الصحفي انجين كارول قبل نحو
30 عاما وستتم المرافعات في ظل غيابي
ترامب بعد اختيار هيئه المحلفين التي
ستقرر قيمه التعويضات التي قد تحصل عليها
صحفيه والبالغه اليوم 79 عاما من جهته نفا
ترامب التهمه ووصفها
بالمختلفه بهدف الشهره
اعلنت قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه عن مقتل احد
عناصرها بعد تعرض سياره القتيل لقصف من
طيران مسير تركي في منطقه كوباني شمال
البلاد بدورها المصد السوري بمقتل شخصين
وباصابه ثالث بجراح خطيره جراء الساده في
طائره مسيره تركيه جنوب كوباني والتي تقع
ضمن مناطق السيطره القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في ريف حلب الشرقي
هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن التغطيه مستمره
دائما على شاشه العربيه بعد قليل تستمر
معكم في المتابعه والتغطيه زميلتي ليان
ابقوا معنا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات